accompany screens job applicants for
illegal drug use at a certain stage in
their hiring process the specific test
they use has a false positive rate of 2%
and a false negative rate of 1% suppose
that 5% of all their applicants are
actually using illegal drugs and we
randomly select an applicant given the
applicant test positive what is the
probability that they are actually on
drugs so let's work through this
together so first let's make sure we
understand what they're telling us so
there is this drug test for the job
applicants and then the test has a false
positive rate of 2% what does that mean
that means that in 2% of the cases when
it should have read negative that the
person didn't do the drugs it actually
read positive it is a false positive it
should have read negative but it read
positive another way to think about it
if someone did not do drugs and you take
this test there's a 2% chance saying
that you did do the illegal drugs they
also say that there is a false negative
rate of 1% what does that mean that
means that 1% of the time if someone did
actually take the illegal drugs it'll
say that they didn't it is falsely
giving a negative result when it should
have given a positive one and then they
say that 5% of all their applicants are
actually using illegal drugs
so there's several ways that we can
think about it one of the easiest ways
to conceptualize is just let's just make
up a large number of applicants and I'll
use a numbers where it's fairly
straightforward to do the mathematics so
let's say that we start off with 10,000
applicants and so I will both talk in
absolute numbers and I just made this
umber up it could have been 1,000 it
could have been a hundred thousand but I
like this number because it's easy to do
the math that have been saying nine
thousand seven hundred and eighty-five
and so this is also going to be one
hundred percent of the
applicants now they give us some crucial
information here they tell us that 5% of
all their applicants are actually using
illegal drugs so we can immediately
break this 10,000 group into the ones
that are doing the drugs and the ones
that are not so 5% are actually on the
drugs 95% are not on the drugs
so what 5% of 10,000
so that would be 500 so 500 on drugs on
drugs and so once again this is 5% of
our original population and then how
many are not on drugs
well 9,500 not not on drugs and once
again this is 95 percent of our group of
applicants so now let's administer the
test so what is going to happen when we
administer the test to the people who
are on drugs well the test ideally would
give a positive result it would say
positive for all of them but we know
that it's not a perfect test it's going
to give negative for some of them it
will falsely give a negative result for
some of them and we know that because it
has a false negative rate of 1% and so
of these 500 99% is going to get the
correct result in that they're going to
test positive so what is 99 percent of
500 let's see that would be 495 495 are
going to test positive I will just use a
positive right over there and then we're
going to have 5 1% 1% which is 5 are
going to test negative they are going to
falsely test negative this is the false
negative rate and so if we say what
percent of our original applicant pool
is on drugs and tests positive well 495
over 10,000 this is four point
nine five percent what percent is of the
original applicant pool that is on drugs
but tests negative for drugs it's it the
test says inane they're not taking drugs
well this is going to be five out of ten
thousand which is 0.05 percent another
way that you could get these percentages
if you take five percent and multiply by
one percent you're going to get 0.05
percent five hundredths of a percent if
you take five percent and multiply by
99% you're going to get four point nine
five percent now let's keep going now
let's go to the folks who aren't taking
the drugs and this is where the false
positive rate is going to come into
effect so we have a false positive rate
of two percent so two percent are going
to test positive what's two percent of
ninety five hundred it's one hundred and
ninety would test positive even though
they're not on drugs this is the false
positive rate so they are testing
positive and then the other 98 percent
will correctly come out negative and so
the other 98 percent so ninety five
hundred minus 190 that's going to be
nine thousand three hundred and ten will
correctly test negative
now what percent of the original
applicant pool is this well 190 is one
point nine percent and we could
calculate it by 190 over 10,000 or you
could just say two percent of ninety
five percent is one point nine percent
once again multiply the path along the
tree what percent is nine thousand three
hundred and ten well that is going to be
ninety 3.10% you could say this is nine
thousand three hundred ten over ten
thousand or you can multiply by the path
on our probability tree here ninety five
percent times ninety eight percent gets
us to ninety three point ten percent but
now I think we are ready to answer the
question
given that the applicant tests positive
what is the probability that they are
actually on drugs so let's look at the
first part given the applicant test
positive so which applicants actually
tested positive you have these 495 here
tested positive correctly tested
positive and then you have these 190
right over here incorrectly tested
positive what they did test positive so
how many tested positive well we have
495 Plus 190 tested positive that's the
total number that tested positive and
then which of them were actually on the
drugs well of the ones that tested
positive 495 were actually on the drugs
we have 495 divided by 495 + 190 is
equal to 0.7 - 2 6
so we could say approximately 72%
approximately 72% now this is really
interesting given the applicant test
positive what is the probability that
they are actually on drugs when you look
at these false positive and false
negative rates they seem quite low but
now when you actually did the
calculation the probability that
someone's actually on drugs is it's high
but it's not that high it's not like if
someone were to test positive that you
say oh they are definitely taking the
drugs and you could also get to this
result just by using the percentages for
example you could think in terms of what
percentage of the original applicants
end up testing positive well that's four
point nine five percent plus one point
nine percent four point nine five and
we'll just do it in terms of percent
plus one point nine percent and of them
what percentage were actually on the
drugs well that was the four point nine
five percent and notice this would give
you the exact same result
now there's an interesting takeaway here
because this is saying of the people
that test positive 72 percent are
actually on the drugs you could think
about it the other way around of the
people who test positive for 95 plus 190
what percentage aren't on drugs
well that was 190 and this comes out to
be approximately 28% 100% minus 72% and
so if we were in a court of law and
let's say the prosecuting attorney let's
say I got tested positive for drugs and
the prosecuting attorney says look this
this test is very good it only has a
false positive rate of 2% Sal and Sal
tested positive
he is probably taking drugs a jury who
doesn't really understand this well or
go through the trouble that we just did
might say oh yeah Sal probably took the
drugs but when we look at this even if I
test positive using this test there's a
twenty eight percent chance that I'm not
taking drugs that I was just in this
false positive group and the reason why
this number is a good bit larger than
this number is because when we looked at
the original division between those who
take drugs and don't take drugs most
don't take the illegal drugs and so two
percent of this larger group of the ones
that don't take the drugs well this is
actually a fairly large number relative
to the percentage that do take the drugs
and test positive so I will leave you
there this is fascinating not just for
this particular case but you will see
analysis like this all the time when
we're looking at whether a certain
medication is effective or a certain
procedure is effective it's important to
be able to do this analysis